nous accueillons ce matin madame la
ministre le Grandjean
chargé de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle pour une
audition qui vient clore les travaux de
la mission d'information de notre
délégation sur le thème formation
compétences et attractivité
madame la ministre s'est en février
dernier que notre délégation a initié ce
cycle de travail dédié à l'enjeu des
compétences
nos trois rapporteurs Martine Berthet
Florence Bertrix compta et Michel
Canevet sont partis la constat
persistant et alarmant celui de
difficulté de recrutement croissant des
entreprises qui peinent à pouvoir les
emplois et attirer les talents alors
même que l'on compte 3 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi dans le pays et que
13% des jeunes entre 15 et 30 ans ne
sont ni en activité ni en formation ni
en études certains secteurs et métiers
sont particulièrement tension y compris
des métiers essentiels pour la vie de
notre nation et son économie dans le
domaine de la santé des transports de
l'enseignement du commerce
face à ce paradoxe il nous est apparu
indispensable de nous pencher à nouveau
sur cet enjeu de société à nouveau car
notre délégation avait déjà tiré la
sonnette d'alarme en 2020 avec un
rapport intitulé des compétences de
toute urgence pour l'emploi et les
entreprises vous pourrez nous rappeler
les mesures prises par le gouvernement
depuis lors pour endiguer ses tensions
qui plus est depuis notre rapport de
2020 la crise covid-19 est passé par là
nous savons qu'elle a entraîné de
nouveaux questionnements sur le sens du
travail sur son organisation et sur
l'équilibre des temps professionnels et
personnels ce profil aussi à l'horizon
d'importantes évolution technologiques
et sectorielle qui vont changer les
métiers et les tâches les transitions
numériques et environnementales je pense
à l'intelligence artificielle ou au
métier liés à la carbonation de
l'industrie les rapporteurs auront tout
à l'heure l'opportunité de vous
interroger sur la manière dont le
gouvernement appréhende ces défis
d'avenir et sur les actions que vous
avez mises en oeuvre pour amorcer
l'adaptation de nos systèmes
d'enseignement le formation et
d'accompagnement des demandeurs d'emploi
avant de vous laisser la parole je
rappelle à nos collègues que vous êtes
chargés au sein du gouvernement
spécifiquement de l'enseignement et de
la formation professionnelle depuis le 4
juillet 2022 votre positionnement est
atypique puisque vous êtes ministre
délégué à la fois auprès du ministre du
Travail du plein emploi et de la station
mais aussi auprès du ministre de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
au cours de la trentaine de missions
menées par les rapporteurs deux messages
sont souvent revenus
tout d'abord le constat de l'éclatement
de l'action publique en matière
d'enseignement et de formation
professionnelle répartie en de très
nombreuses acteurs selon des modalités
complexes ensuite je tiens à le dire
qu'il y a les appréciations positives
sont parfois rares on a également
souligné votre regard croisé sur ces
enjeux depuis votre arrivée au
gouvernement cela souvent été salué par
les interlocuteurs tenez à vous le dire
nous appelons régulièrement ici au Sénat
à ce que l'État dépasse son
fonctionnement en silo justement exact
contraire de ce que vous tentez de faire
encore trop fréquent je fais d'ailleurs
le vœu devant vous Madame le Ministre
que les entreprises soient aussi
associées à ce regard croisé par le
gouvernement et l'administration dans la
mise en oeuvre des réformes importantes
qui se profilent dans un proche à venir
réforme du lycée professionnel création
de France travail projet de loi pleine
emploi nous sommes dans une période
charnière et stratégique pour les
compétences qui méritent un vrai
dialogue entre état école et entreprises
je vous salue tout d'abord la parole
pour un propos liminaire d'une durée de
20 minutes environ puis les trois
rapporteurs de la mission d'information
vous poseront leurs questions ainsi que
nos collègues présents pour les échanges
qui le font s'arrêter au plus tard à 10h
pour respecter l'agenda de chacun je
vous prierai de bien veiller utiliser
vos micro qui sont nécessaires à la
bonne captation du visuelle elle a
retranscription de nos échanges et je
vous remercie vous laisse la parole
Madame le Ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
Berthet blatrix compta et canevé je suis
très heureuse d'être parmi vous
effectivement aujourd'hui pour
participer dans le cadre de la mission
d'information que vous conduisez pour
évoquer ce sujet des compétences de la
formation professionnelle et plus
globalement de l'attractivité des
métiers qui nous le savons sont au cœur
de d'un certain nombre de développements
et notamment économique mais aussi
sociétaux ils sont également au cœur de
la feuille de route qui est la mienne en
tant que ministre chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle et comme vous l'avez
rappelé au fond trait d'union entre le
ministère du Travail et le ministère de
l'Éducation nationale aux côtés
d'Olivier du soft et de Pape Andy
nous partageons je le crois une
conviction qui est celui que notre
système de formation doit mieux
permettre aux actifs de faire face aux
mutations en cours ou à venir vous
l'avez justement évoqué dans vos
dernières rapports nos perceptions du
monde du travail ont été bouleversées
non seulement dans nos méthodes mais
aussi dans nos pratiques
professionnelles il est évident que le
marché du travail évolue et que cette
accélération s'est intensifié ces
dernières années notre système de
formation doit donc refléter ces
évolutions afin de préparer les grandes
transitions que vous avez évoqué celles
de l'écologie du numérique de la
démographie mais aussi s'adapter aux
fonds aspirations des citoyens qui après
notamment la période covid mais déjà
auparavant aspire de plus en plus à
prendre le contrôle de leur avenir
professionnel
il nous faut donc mettre en oeuvre un
ajustement permanent et cohérent entre
l'offre de formation qui est proposée
aux actifs et les besoins réels des
entreprises et avec une rénovation de
notre appareil de formation qui ne doit
pas seulement combler les retards mais
aussi aller de l'avant et être surtout
plus agile et plus accessible pour nos
concitoyens en premier lieu je voudrais
dire que nous devons absolument
renforcer la capacité d'insertion
professionnelle de la voie
professionnelle qui a été trop longtemps
délaissé c'est un enjeu que je porte au
travers de la réforme du lycée
professionnel vous le savez on en a déjà
parlé au sein de votre chambre mais les
lycées professionnels accueillent chaque
année un lycéen sur 3 c'est
621000 élèves en lycée professionnel
auxquels s'ajoutent 64
000 apprentis pourtant elle concentre
davantage de difficultés que la voix
générale et technologique et nous devons
accompagner plus ces jeunes qui trop
souvent sont en échec aujourd'hui moins
d'un bachelier professionnel sur deux
parvient à s'insérer dans l'emploi six
mois après l'obtention de son diplôme
c'est clairement une injustice c'est
aussi clairement un enjeu de cohésion
sociale et dans nos jeux économique pour
le pays pour aller répondre aux enjeux
de tension sur les recrutements et
notamment sur des secteurs essentiels
pour notre économie et on pourra en
citer beaucoup ceux de l'industrie ceux
de l'énergie ceux de la restauration du
BTP du soin enfin j'en passe ils sont en
tension et sur les 15 métiers les plus
intentions 10 sont
issus finalement formés par la voie
professionnelle pour cela nous donnons
nous nous donnons les moyens de réussir
c'est plus d'un milliard d'euros
supplémentaires par an qui ira à la voie
professionnelle aujourd'hui le budget
consacré à la voix professionnelle de
4,9 milliards d'euros il va donc être
augmenté d'un milliard d'euros par an
supplémentaire auquel s'ajoute bien sûr
les revalorisations socle versées à
l'ensemble des enseignants auxquels
s'ajoute un chargé de relations
entreprises dans chaque établissement
lycée professionnel demain auquel
s'ajoutent les annonces que j'ai fait de
maintien des effectifs du nombre de
professeurs d'enseignants en lycée
professionnel à la rentrée prochaine et
auquel s'ajoute deux choses
supplémentaires 400 ETP que j'ai annoncé
pour accompagner les équipes
enseignantes avec plus de CPE conseiller
principaux d'éducation de d'infirmiers
d'assistance sociaux dans ces
établissements qui encore une fois
regroupe plus de fragilité sociale quand
on voit général et technologique et un
accompagnement par France 2030 et
milliards d'euros seront mis dans le
cadre des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt compétences et métiers
d'avenir pour accompagner la mise en
place avec les régions de nouveaux
plateaux techniques pour accompagner
également la formation des enseignants
ainsi que l'attractivité la mise en
visibilité de certains métiers d'avenir
je voudrais rappeler que la réforme elle
a trois grands leviers elle a été
annoncée par le président de la
République le 4 mai dernier avec trois
grands leviers le premier qui vise à
mieux accompagner ces jeunes dans les
fragilités scolaires sont plus grandes
et lutter contre le décrochage le second
vise à accompagner mieux l'insertion
professionnelle de ces jeunes et à avoir
un système de formation qui soit plus en
réponse à nos enjeux économiques et puis
enfin le troisième et dernier grand
levier qui était essentiel aussi bien
sûr c'est celui de donner aux équipes
éducatives les moyens d'agir et de
valoriser l'engagement de ses
professeurs je détaillerai ici devant
vous le deuxième levier de cette réforme
structurelle donc encore une fois
l'objectif est l'évolution des
formations qui sont proposées en lycée
professionnel pour les adapter aux
besoins de l'économie et pour fermer des
formations qui sont insuffisamment
cohérentes par rapport au métier
d'aujourd'hui et de demain et
permettent insuffisamment la réussite de
la poursuite d'études l'objectif ici est
clair et le président de la République
l'a rappelé lors de l'annonce de cette
réforme permet ici
la rentrée 2026 toutes les formations
qui n'ouvrent pas de perspective
d'emploi ni de poursuite d'études
suffisante il s'agit donc de transformer
la carte des formations l'offre de
formation dans les lycées professionnels
c'est évidemment une opération difficile
mais qui existe déjà on a chaque année
déjà des fermetures de formation
d'autres ouvertures mais lorsqu'on
constate une insertion professionnelle
qui est objectivement n'est pas bonne
après l'obtention du diplôme il nous
faut agir et réagir donc pour
accompagner cette cette évolution de la
fraude formation nous allons donc mettre
je lisais tout à l'heure en place via
France 2030 des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt pour accompagner la mise en
place de nouveaux plateaux techniques et
cette accélération qui je le rappelle
est du ressort des régions de la
compétence des régions pour pouvoir
financement mais dans la mesure où nous
souhaitons engager une accélération
forte nous avons pris l'engagement de
co-financer ces plateaux techniques avec
les régions France 2030 permettra les
budgets de l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt permettront également de
d'accompagner la formation des
professeurs et des proviseurs pour
accompagner aussi cette évolution
culturelle et cette évolution technique
de l'offre de formation c'est également
et je me permets de d'insister là dessus
un budget conséquent qui sera mis en
oeuvre sur la mise en visibilité et en
attractivité de certaines filières
d'avenir qui sont donc de fait souvent
méconnus par les élèves par les familles
par les professeurs au font par la
société bien souvent et donc il s'agit
véritablement de mettre en visibilité
ces filières métiers nouvelles
des outils de pilotage seront également
déployés pour mesurer les taux
d'insertion et les taux de poursuite
d'études en formation par formation par
formation il s'agit véritablement
d'avoir du coup un suivi et une mise en
transparence pour les familles et les
élèves mais aussi un suivi pour les
établissements pour faire évoluer
l'offre de formation et mieux répondre
aux enjeux économiques la création aussi
de formation de spécialisation post-bac
en cohérence avec les entreprises
locales est également une modalité très
attendue des entreprises et permet au
lycéen de parfaire leur formation dans
le domaine donc
post-baccalauréat professionnel et avec
un effet très clair sur l'insertion
professionnelle puisque ces jeunes qui
déjà passent dans le cadre de FCL
formation complémentaire d'initiative
locale dans certains territoires on
observe plus 20 points d'employabilité à
l'issue de ces mentions complémentaires
très alternantes très métier très en
cohérence avec le marché du travail
local c'est donc ce que nous souhaitons
développer il y en a il y a aujourd'hui
4500 places aujourd'hui de formation en
France nous irons sur un objectif de
20.000 d'ici à la rentrée 2026
enfin bien que les élèves de lycée
professionnel alternent courent et
stages en entreprise il est pas toujours
facile pour eux de trouver un stage déjà
de trouver un stage de trouver un stage
en cohérence avec leur formation et de
trouver un stage de qualité et donc il
s'agit pour moi de travailler à ce
réseau professionnel et par la mise en
place d'un bureau des entreprises qui
sera donc créé dans chaque lycée
professionnel dès la rentrée prochaine
et donc permettra aux entreprises de vos
territoires de facilement proposer des
stages aux jeunes de facilement
organiser un dialogue avec les
établissements d'avoir une personne
dédiée et identifiée pour ces
c'est un vrai enjeu de développement du
temps et de la qualité des stages de
l'alternance mais aussi de l'orientation
information insertion des publics
accueillis dans les lycées
professionnels le deuxième grand volet
que je de mon action que je voulais
évoquer c'est celui de l'apprentissage
vous le savez notre effort pour
l'apprentissage est massif les résultats
de cette action sont incontestables
puisque nous sommes passés de de 280 000
contrats d'apprentissage en 2017 à près
de 840 000 contrats en 2022 soit plus du
double presque le triple par rapport aux
années 2012-2017 notre détermination ne
doit néanmoins pas faillir notre
objectif est fixé par le président de la
République et nous le partageons avec
Olivier du soft c'est celui d'atteindre
un million d'apprentis par an d'ici à la
fin du quinquennat cet objectif
qualitatif nous devons le doubler bien
sûr aussi d'un objectif qualitatif pour
non seulement monter en puissance le
nombre d'apprentis mais aussi la de
qualité des apprentissages et ses
travaux sont d'ores et déjà engagés avec
les acteurs de la formation et notamment
les centres de formation par
apprentissage nous avons également
concernant le financement de
l'apprentissage à mon sens trois
éléments que nous pouvons partager le
premier c'est que en 2023 l'état
investit aux côtés des entreprises dans
le financement de l'apprentissage à
travers une subvention votée en loi de
finances initiale il ne s'agit pas pour
le gouvernement donc de rééquilibrer les
comptes de France compétences il s'agit
très clairement d'envoyer un signal
puissant de soutien de l'État dans le
financement de la formation initiale par
la voix de l'apprentissage le deuxième
point que je souhaitais valoriser pour
soutenir la mobilisation des entreprises
dans l'accueil des apprentis nous avons
décidé de prolonger l'aide accordée pour
le recrutement d'un apprenti jusqu'à la
fin du quinquennat c'est la première
fois qu'on donne une visibilité de ce
type de manière plus Ryan et je tenais
ici à le souligner et puis je tenais
également à souligner le fait que c'est
un engagement fort parce qu'il vient au
travers d'une aide d'un dispositif qui
est simple unique lisible puisque l'aide
s'élève je vous le rappelle à 6000 euros
pour tous les apprentis quel que soit la
taille de l'entreprise quel que soit le
niveau de qualification je tiens à
rappeler donc que l'effort est donc
supplémentaire notamment pour les
apprentis mineurs qui sont souvent les
plus faiblement qualifiés et donc c'est
un soutien que je souhaite souligner à
ce titre et puis le troisième point que
je voulais souligner sur la partie
financement de l'apprentissage c'est
relatif à la prise en charge des
contrats nous devons poursuivre les
travaux engagés en septembre 2021 pour
viser encore une fois le juste prix de
chaque certification le processus de
révision je vous le rappelle avait été
initié en septembre 2022 avec un premier
un premier niveau de baisse nous avons
décalé la seconde baisse à septembre
afin de ne pas mettre en difficulté la
rentrée des centres de formation par
apprentissage et de se laisser le temps
de documenter l'impact notamment de
l'inflation sur le modèle économique des
CFA mais également une demande que nous
leur faisons dans la partie discussion
sur la qualité de la mise en oeuvre
aussi dans leur contenu de formation des
évolutions sur la transition écologique
sur la transition numérique et sur la
transition démographique qui sont trois
aspects qui doit pouvoir être absolument
accompagné dans chacune des formations
le troisième point que je souhaitais
évoquer ce matin c'est celui des
contenus de formation
au delà du renouveau de l'accessibilité
des formations il s'agit véritablement
aussi de travailler sur le contenu des
formations l'enjeu de la révision des
certifications professionnelles et
struct de la rénovation de la formation
en effet nous n'aurons pas de formation
de qualité si les objectifs ne sont pas
définis d'une manière suffisamment
précise et ambitieuse alors ça peut
paraître technique et pour autant c'est
fondamental je voudrais juste citer
quelques diplômes qui ont déjà été
révisés comme celui de diplôme de bac de
BTS de la filière cybersécurité
informatique et réseaux électroniques ou
le cap grand âge ou encore la mention
complémentaire aide à domicile qui ont
été conçus pour répondre aux défis du
vieillissement démographique et de la
société de la longévité c'est essentiel
que nos contenus s'adaptent aussi aux
évolutions sociétales et à ceux du
marché du travail c'est donc
indispensable et vous le disiez monsieur
le Président d'amener plus
systématiquement le ministères
certificateurs et les 11 commissions
professionnelles consultatives à
s'aligner sur les standards exigeants de
France compétences et c'est donc
pourquoi j'ai proposé à la première
ministre de mandat l'établissement
public France compétences pour faire le
point sur la diversité des pratiques et
sur l'expérience accumulée depuis
quelques années maintenant d'ici à l'été
cette mission devra nous faire des
propositions sur les évolutions à
apporter pour que notre système gagne
encore en pertinence en efficacité et en
agilité il importe par ailleurs que
c'est que les certifications évoluent au
même rythme que la transformation des
métiers c'est un enjeu majeur un point
au fond cardinal que vous avez déjà
soulevé et c'est donc très clairement un
point que je partage avec vous et qui
doit être un engagement pris par les
ministères certificateurs c'est pourquoi
j'ai d'ailleurs décidé l'installation à
l'AFPA d'une mission interministérielle
qui proposera ses services pour
accélérer la transformation des titres
et des diplômes et améliorer la qualité
de cela de manière interministérielle
je voudrais en quatrième point aborder
la nation des compétences qui est aussi
celle de garantir une formation continue
qui permette d'accompagner chaque jour
un peu mieux les trajectoires
professionnelles et les reconversions
des actifs je voudrais d'abord
continuer à soutenir le compte personnel
de formation mais pour de bonnes et
mauvaises raisons réponds raison ce CPF
et désormais connu de presque tous les
Français 9 Français sur 10 on a entendu
parler il a incontestablement trouvé son
public puisque les Français y ont
fortement recours nous sommes donc
passés de 600 000 dossiers en 2019 à
plus de 2 millions en 2022 et 4,5
millions de téléchargements de
l'application
mais entre le démarchage abusif les
formations loisirs et la fraude la
notoriété positive de ce dispositif a
été altéré le CPF reste pourtant un très
bel outil au de nombreux enjeux de
compétences et ces phénomènes et cette
communication ont parfois masquée le
progrès immense que représente mon
compte formation rendre l'accès à la
formation possible pour toutes et tous
c'est la raison pour laquelle depuis
plus d'un an nous avons mené des actions
fortes pour réguler l'offre disponible
aujourd'hui plus personne ne peut dire
que l'on trouve des formations loisirs
en ligne ou qu'ils reçoivent
quotidiennement des SMS de démarchage
nous avons agi les résultats sont au
rendez-vous je pourrais revenir dans le
cadre de nos échanges si vous le
souhaitez mais le CPF je le redis
constitue une avancée sociale importante
dans la démocratisation du droit à la
formation notre action de régulation
vise avant tout pour à créer les
conditions de sa pérennité et sa
meilleure articulation entre les
dispositifs
avec la VAE et cette nouvelle version de
la VAE nous allons valoriser les
compétences acquises au cours de la vie
pour fluidifier les parcours des actifs
je vous le rappelle à ce jour seul 10%
des personnes qui s'engagent dans une
VAE vont au bout de leur parcours et
obtiennent l'intégralité de la
certification visée et surtout la durée
moyenne d'un parcours et de 18 mois et
donc n'est pas adapté à la réalité des
parcours des actifs et de leur parcours
de vie comme de leur parcours
professionnel donc rien d'étonnant à ce
qu'elle soit deux fois moins mobilisée
qu'il y a 10 ans avec seulement 30 000
parcours par an j'ai donc décidé en 2022
de conduire une transformation de la VAE
initié par le vote de la loi du 21
décembre 2022 portant mesure d'urgence
au fonctionnement du marché du travail
en vue du plein emploi qui nous
permettra donc de multiplier par 3 le
nombre de bénéficiaires d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat de VAE notre objectif est
clair c'est un dispositif plus moderne
qui est visé
allégée administrativement et que nous
doterons d'une plateforme numérique
dédiée plus rapide et qui se conclut par
des succès plus nombreux notamment par
un accompagnement renforcé j'ai
également souhaité que ce déploie sur
tout le territoire et pour tous les
métiers en tension une expérimentation
dite de VAE inversée on pourra y revenir
si vous le souhaitez mais au fond elle
est fondée sur le principe de
l'acquisition de l'expérience en cours
de parcours et non en amont de celui-ci
une expérimentation qui traduit une
volonté marquée de mon ministère de
d'innover en matière de formation et de
répondre à court terme aux enjeux de
tension sur des métiers et de et de
valoriser également cette expérience
professionnelle par le biais d'un
diplôme reconnaissance qui en France est
toujours très importante ces évolutions
elles traduisent véritablement un
changement de culture qui place la la
connaissance des compétences acquises au
cœur des trajectoires professionnelles
et puis nous souhaitons profondément
simplifier les dispositifs de transition
professionnelle
entre ProA le PTP les transitions
collectives les démissions reconversion
j'ai citerai pas tous mais tous les
dispositifs de transition
professionnelle son nombreux et les
entreprises comme les actifs ont du mal
à s'y retrouver
si bien que les parcours de transition
de transition professionnelle ne
concerne aujourd'hui que 0,3% des
salariés du privé par an c'est 60 000
parcours annuels c'est dire que nous
sommes loin de la réalité de l'enjeu des
mutations professionnelles et des
reconversions qui doivent pouvoir être
engagés il y a donc de quoi s'interroger
quand on sait que nous sommes amenés à
changer d'emploi plusieurs fois au cours
de notre carrière qu'un jeune qui rentre
aujourd'hui dans un parcours
professionnel de métier entre 13 et 15
fois c'est dire que nous ne sommes à la
hauteur de l'enjeu des transitions
professionnelles et donc il convient de
poser cette question des transitions
professionnelles qui est véritablement
pour moi un enjeu de cohésion et de
cohésion sociétale et de compétitivité
économique face aux mutations
économiques technologiques
environnementales il est donc de notre
devoir d'apporter des réponses aux
conséquences parfois brutales des
changements de modèles qui s'accélèrent
je le disais tout à l'heure je pense par
exemple aux mutations de la filière
automobile et des services à
l'automobile qui doivent nous conduire à
mieux anticiper accompagner les salariés
et les entreprises qui sont concernées
vers des reconversions car tous ne
resteront pas dans ces secteurs
d'activité c'est pourquoi je souhaite
clarifier et simplifier ces dispositifs
d'accompagnement des transitions voire
en supprimer ces constats sont largement
partagés avec les partenaires sociaux
nous verront dans les prochaines
semaines qui viennent dans quelle mesure
ils placent ces éléments dans l'agenda
social qu'ils élaborent voilà Mesdames
et Messieurs les Sénateurs vous l'aurez
compris nos chantiers sont immenses je
n'ai pas pu traiter dans ce propos
liminaire tous les enjeux mais bien sûr
je répondrai à toutes vos questions pour
les traiter je crois qu'il nous faut de
la conviction de l'ambition mais aussi
une certaine humilité la réponse elle
n'est pas une et unique face aux besoins
des entreprises et de notre économie les
réponses elles offrent au fond enfin les
mesures offrent des réponses de cours de
moyens et de plus long terme et donc ils
doivent pouvoir s'articuler les uns les
autres de manière à pouvoir avoir une
réponse d'ampleur et à être traitée avec
méthode pour avoir des réponses adaptées
qui s'inscrivent dans ce dans ces
espaces temporels que j'évoquais avec la
formation des demandeurs d'emploi ou
avec la réforme de la VAE on se met en
situation d'apporter à court terme une
réponse aux besoins des secteurs en
tension en même temps que nous sécuris
les parcours des individus avec
l'apprentissage et la réforme du lycée
professionnel ce sont des réponses à
plus moyen terme pour toute une jeunesse
qui sera formée à des métiers qui
garantissent une insertion durable dans
l'emploi dans des secteurs d'avenir et
enfin en s'appuyant sur des leviers
comme France 2030 et notamment l'appel à
manifestation d'intérêt compétences et
métiers d'avenir et des 2,5 milliards
d'euros d'investissement c'est toute une
offre de formation initiale et continue
qui est en évolution pour donner à notre
pays le capital humain et être au
rendez-vous de la compétition mondiale
de 2030 pour terminer je voudrais juste
dire que si c'est à l'état de proposer
un horizon et de fixer les principales
règles c'est bien bien sûr avec les
entreprises les partenaires sociaux les
acteurs territoriaux qui font partie
intégrante de cette écosystème et enfin
de tous les acteurs impliqués que nous
devons finalement penser et conduire ce
changement de manière très con Crète
voilà je vous remercie et essuie à vos
dispositions bien sûr pour répondre à
toutes les questions
merci beaucoup madame la ministre pour
ce vaste tour d'horizon
beaucoup d'éléments positifs nous
intéressent évidemment des
questionnements dont je passe la parole
successivement rapporteur commençant par
Martine merci
cependant les entreprises regrettent
qu'elle n'est pas
la main entre guillemets sur les
formations de leurs salariés et
particulièrement lorsqu'il s'agit de
reconversion professionnelle en vue
d'aborder la phase seniors de ces
salariés et d'adapter leur poste de
travail leur métier donc voilà au niveau
de ce CPF comment pensez-vous le faire
évoluer je vous remercie
très bien merci Madame la rapporteur
Berthet effectivement de questions
essentielles concernant le déficit de
France compétences je pourrais dire
beaucoup de choses donc je vais essayer
de d'être
synthétique et en même temps complexe au
fond c'est vrai que l'investissement
réalisé dans la formation des jeunes et
des actifs et très clairement au coeur
de notre projet politique et notamment
d'une réforme importante celle de 2018
avec le développement à l'échelle de
l'apprentissage et de cette
démocratisation du CPF qui ont eu un
impact très fort sur le la dépense
quelque part en formation cet
investissement important qui a eu je me
permets de le dire parce que je n'ai pas
dit en propos liminaire de dispositif
qui ont eu un effet formidable sur à la
fois l'accès à la formation de public
qui jusque-là était plus éloignée des
dispositifs et je pense aux ouvriers
employés mais aussi aux femmes
aujourd'hui
ils sont
7,7 sur 10 bénéficiaires qui sont
ouvriers employés alors qu'auparavant on
constaté que c'était plutôt de 7 sur 10
cadres qui bénéficiaient de la formation
et nous avons 50% de femmes or on sait
qu'elles sont souvent sur des métiers
avec plus de fragilité et des plus de
temps partiels etc et puis que
l'apprentissage permet à cette jeune sur
10 de rentrer dans l'emploi donc c'est
un je crois véritablement que c'est un
c'est un succès quelque part d'avoir
développé ces politiques là pourtant la
cuve pas donc cette cotisation des
entreprises ne couvre pas ne couvrent
pas l'entièreté des dépenses c'est
pourquoi l'État agit ces dernières
années par effet de responsabilité dans
le dans un octroi de 4,7 milliards
d'euros à France compétences par exemple
en 2022 donc avec un accompagnement pour
garantir les dynamiques qui ont été en
classe enclenchées politiquement par
aussi des décisions politiques et ce aux
politiques de formation il s'accompagne
aussi de mesures concrètes de régulation
qui que je citais tout à l'heure qui
vise à mieux maîtriser la trajectoire
Financière de France compétences d'abord
la baisse des coûts et qui est
intervenue en septembre 2022 avec une
seconde
vague de baisse des coûts qui est prévu
pour septembre 2023 comme je l'évoquais
tout à l'heure mais qui doit être fait
dans le cadre d'une réflexion avec les
acteurs sur à la fois la qualité de la
formation que je souhaite qu'il renforce
et notamment avec les grandes
transitions qu'ils doivent intégrer dans
leur contenu de formation mais également
avec les effets de l'inflation qui doit
pouvoir être pris en compte et donc le
tout sur la base de la comptabilité
analytique des organismes de formation
et sur ce dialogue que nous aurons au
travers de l'impact de ces de ces sujets
là mais nous avons également travaillé
sur l'assainissement de l'offre
notamment sur les formations la création
d'entreprise nous avons également
travaillé sur la régulation au travers
de la de la régulation des organismes de
formation eux-mêmes qui parfois n'était
pas de qualité suffisante et nos propos
et pas une offre de qualité suffisante
et je voudrais également rappeler que
nous avons fait un très gros travail
autour de la sécurisation
au travers de France Connect plus parce
que nous avions un certain nombre de
fraudes
d'abus et plus globalement mais de
fraude notamment à l'accès aux comptes
personnel de formation donc avec un
accès plus sécurisé qu'hier de manière à
éviter un certain nombre de fraudes et
de démarchage abusifs au travers des
dispositions que nous avons pris par le
biais d'une proposition de loi c'est
donc vraiment dans l'idée à la fois un
accompagnement sur la régulation un
accompagnement aussi par l'État et je me
permets de le redire pour la première
fois dans le budget initial
pour 2023 un soutien de l'État aux
politiques qui sont publiques qui sont
engagés au travers de l'apprentissage
notamment et puis plugalement un une
volonté bien sûr de de travailler avec
France compétences sur cette régulation
du CPF des et des aider pardon des coûts
contrats pour que nous puissions avoir
une une meilleure maîtrise de la dépense
c'est je le rappelle une gouvernance
quad répartite qui est celui de France
compétences et donc c'est évidemment
avec ces acteurs que nous travaillons à
la suite de de la dépense et des
investissements et de la de de la
conduite finalement des actions par
France compétence le concernant le CPF
je voudrais donc redire qu'effectivement
c'est 2 millions d'utilisateurs par an
donc une démocratisation inédite de la
formation avec ce nouveau public je le
rappelais il est connu par à 10% des
Français dont je crois qu'en cela c'est
une vraie réussite c'est une vraie
réussite qui s'est accompagnée aussi de
fraude et de démarchage abusives sur
laquelle nous avons souhaité travailler
fort et aujourd'hui je crois que nous
pouvons dire que nous ne recevons plus
de SMS de démarchage comme nous pouvions
la voir nous nous recevons plus voilà de
de
constatons plus en fait de tout
simplement de fraude comme on le
constatait et ça c'est voilà le rapport
que nous font les les gendarmes
notamment qui constate un certain nombre
de fraudes et de fraude différentes
cette fin du démarchage abusif et
d'usurpation d'identité elle est le
fruit de la loi contre les fraudes elle
est aussi le fruit de cette évolution
par France Connect plus
nous avons engagé des discussions et
nous souhaitons engager des discussions
avec les partenaires sociaux vous le
savez ils ont fait une contribution
paritaire dans le cadre de la suite de
la nationale interprofessionnels qu'ils
avaient déjà réalisé sur la formation
professionnelle un certain nombre de
propositions sont faits par les
partenaires sociaux et notamment au
travers de mécanismes d'abondement qui
pourront faire l'objet de nouvelles
discussions nous attendons de savoir
dans quel niveau de priorité il
remettent ces discussions là à l'ordre
du jour mais nous souhaitons pouvoir
engager des discussions avec les
partenaires sociaux sur ces aspects là
parce que nous devons travailler à ce
que le compte personnel de formation
soit un mieux orienté sur les projets
professionnels et qu'ils accompagnent
mieux
un projet à viser de
véritablement d'évolution ou de
reconversion professionnelle et de il
doit être également mieux articuler avec
les autres dispositifs que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure la validation des acides
d'expérience et dispositifs de
transition professionnelle et donc il
doit pouvoir être la mécanique aussi de
financement de ce qui complète des
parcours qui sont aussi engagés par
ailleurs c'est à dire si je engage une
validation des acquis d'expérience il va
me manquer tel ou tel bloc de
compétences pour aller acquérir tel
certification et donc mieux cibler la
formation pour qu'elle concourt
véritablement un projet professionnel et
que l'investissement soit
mieux enfin plus en adéquation
finalement avec les enjeux économiques
et du marché mais aussi évidemment d'un
projet pour l'individu
pour suivre avec Florence latex compta
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'aurais également deux
questions la première sur l'orientation
de nombreuses personnes au cours de nos
auditions nous ont indiqué que
l'orientation était un petit peu de
l'angle mort des politiques du
gouvernement et on s'aperçut qu'il y a
eu finalement très peu d'avancées ces
dernières années sur ce point alors même
que les problèmes sont nombreux et
connus toujours une image très dégradée
de la voie professionnelle alors qu'elle
est très insérante voire même plus
insérante parfois même plus
rémunératrice et porteuse de sens on
voit même aujourd'hui des ingénieurs qui
se reconvertissent et veulent devenir
boulanger ou boucher
une féminisation insuffisante aussi de
certaines formations professionnelles et
notamment scientifiques une
méconnaissance des métiers par les
personnels d'enseignement les
interlocuteurs de l'État et un
éclatement des compétences
entre région et état dont on ne voit pas
encore réellement les résultats donc il
nous a semblé avec tous les témoignages
qu'on a qu'on a eu qu'il faut aller plus
loin sur ce point rapprocher davantage
l'école du monde de l'entreprise et
faciliter les les la connaissance
mutuelle les transitions et ça
contribuerait aussi à prévenir le
décrochage et éviter des parcours
d'éloignement de l'emploi donc quels
sont vos propositions en la matière et
seriez-vous prêt c'est un autre point
qui nous semble important à intégrer
davantage la découverte des métiers dans
le cursus scolaire il y a par exemple le
stage de troisième mais on s'aperçoit
que qu'en réalité les élèves ont
beaucoup de mal à trouver une entreprise
et ils vont souvent dans leur cercle
familial ou amical pour trouver une
entreprise donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut accompagner les les élèves vers des
stages qui soient plus utiles pour eux
ma seconde enfin question c'était aussi
un témoignage sur l'offre de formation
vous l'avez évoqué
la loi à venir professionnelle de 2018
a apporté à une ouverture de la forme de
formation tant qu'initiale avec on
facilitant l'ouverture de CFA que
continue avec aujourd'hui un grand
nombre d'acteurs et 5 ans après on
s'aperçoit que d'un côté la réforme a
bien fonctionné les entreprises nous
disent que le maillage la formation des
CFA a gagné en qualité mais il nous
semble aussi je vous l'avais relevé que
l'effort de simplification n'est pas
allé assez loin nous avons eu par
exemple l'école algo sup qui répond à un
vrai besoin de formation sur les
compétences d'avenir et qui nous dit
avoir subi un véritable parcours du
combattant pour faire valider son cursus
malgré le fastract pour c'est être mis
en oeuvre et du côté de France
compétences un certification des
formations professionnelles prend
toujours
trop de temps c'est un témoignage que
que l'on a eu dans d'autres cas
l'inverse il semble y avoir des abus
encore un article de presse hier sur les
formations privées notamment dans le
supérieur montrent les abus des clauses
abusives des faux diplômes et
on pense aussi qu'il manque de
régulation sur ce type de formation
privée qui ont beaucoup bénéficié
d'ailleurs et qui se sont financés en
partie grâce au développement de
l'apprentissage donc comment allez-vous
accentuer le contrôle et peut-être pour
pour aller plus loin est-ce que dans les
domaines qui sont d'offres de formation
qui sont proposées dans ces écoles
est-ce qui finalement il n'y a pas un
manque dans les offres publiques
notamment dans les les universités dans
l'enseignement supérieur je vous
remercie
merci Madame la rapporteur blatex compta
je partage avec vous pleinement le fait
que l'enjeu d'orientation et essentiel
je me permets de le rappeler mais font
la compétence de l'orientation et celle
de la région depuis 2018 et et c'est un
enjeu immense parce que si nous
souhaitons passer à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de la jeunesse c'est un enjeu
qui en fait une complexité immense parce
qu'il faut pouvoir aller chercher chacun
des jeunes finalement chacun des jeunes
dans chacun de ces territoires et avec
cette même volonté d'égalité des chances
et de l'accès à l'information ce qui
n'est pas du tout évident et donc je ne
jette la pierre à personne et pour
autant nous pouvons dire que
effectivement le le la réalité de
l'information sur l'orientation et de et
de l'orientation en elle-même elle n'est
elle n'a pas beaucoup évolué ces
dernières années c'est pourquoi depuis
cette rentrée 2023 nous avons considéré
que nous devons être
puisse partenaire avec les régions pour
pouvoir travailler avec elle
laissant bien sûr leurs compétences
d'orientation et il ne s'agit pas de
revenir sur le sujet mais pour autant
parce que à l'éducation nationale nous
avons finalement cette capacité de
passer à l'échelle c'est un mot un peu
moche à dire comme ça mais de
massification aussi de l'information
nous avons décidé d'organiser au sein
des établissements et donc de chaque
établissement et de chaque classe de 5e
4e 3e une organisation de la découverte
des métiers on l'a mis sous forme
expérimentale en à la rentrée 2023 c'est
10% des collèges qui ont d'ores et déjà
engagés cette découverte des métiers
c'est 650 collèges qui ont déployé la
découverte des métiers hier j'étais dans
un collège en Centre-Val de Loire et
deux proviseur c'était vraiment un
concours de circonstances de proviseur
emmener 50 élèves chacune
dans dans visiter le lycée professionnel
et donc les métiers qui qui était
enseigné et c'est vraiment une
initiative que nous souhaitons donc
maintenant déployer dans l'ensemble des
collèges de France dès la rentrée qui
arrive donc c'était la rentrée 2022
pardon et donc c'est la rentrée 2023
pardon qui arrive qui va permettre de
déployer cette découverte des médecines
dans tous les collèges de France 5e 3e
l'idée est véritablement de faire
découvrir des familles de métiers
sans sans quelque part orienter le jeune
sur le choix qui pourra être le sien et
sans quelque part informer uniquement
sur des métiers en tension où je ne sais
quoi donc de véritablement organiser une
information large et globale sur les
familles de métiers et permettre aux
jeunes de se rendre compte des métiers
divers qui composent ces familles de
métiers ça leur permettra un d'avoir une
meilleure information sur les métiers
souvent les jeunes s'orientent sur la
dizaine de métiers qu'ils connaissent
autour de la dixième unité qu'il
connaisse qui sont souvent ceux de
l'entourage familial et il s'agit donc
de dépasser là il s'agit d'aller faire
connaître des métiers en tension d'aller
dépasser des stéréotypes de genre
d'aller travailler aussi sur d'autres
stéréotypes ou représentation que
certains jeunes peuvent avoir sur
certaines filières métiers et puis
d'aller aussi parler des métiers qui
n'existent pas encore ou pas beaucoup et
qui donc doivent pouvoir être mieux
connus par ces jeunes c'est donc
véritablement dès la rentrée prochaine
un vrai partenariat qu'on engage avec
les régions pour ouvrir le collège et
engager le collège à cette découverte
des métiers et qui viendra donc
accompagner Jean dire suppléer le stage
de 3e qui restera une étape mais qui ne
sera qu'une étape et d'ailleurs en
discutait hier avec les deux proviseurs
de collège qui était présente en disant
au fond une année qui est assez
stratégique dans la découverte des
métiers c'est la quatrième parce que en
fait une fois que le jeûne est déjà en
troisième les choses s'enchaînent ça va
très vite l'information a du mal à
circuler entre l'enfant la famille
euh le le le les établissements et
cetera donc tout va très vite donc il
s'agit en fait de plus anticiper et de
commencer dès la quatrième enfin nous on
commencera dès la 5e et dès la 4e c'est
une année assez charnière pour que le
projet puisse se construire se
construire progressivement dans le temps
de permettre justement aux jeunes
d'aller visiter une entreprise d'aller
rencontrer tel professionnel c'est ce
que nous allons organiser des visites
d'entreprise des professionnels qui
viendront dans les établissements
scolaires des déplacements dans des
lycées professionnels des professeurs de
lycée professionnel qui viendront dans
les collèges quelque part accompagner
bien sûr de l'Onisep qui fait un travail
formidable et quelque part c'est
aussi par cette par ce collectif qui va
travailler ensemble que chacun
comprendra mieux la réalité des métiers
famille comme élève comme enseignant
comme entreprise on partagera mieux au
fond ce que ce que ce que sont la
réalité des métiers qui souvent sont
font le son
voilà
un postéréotypés par les uns et par les
autres et mérite d'être dépassé c'est
vraiment un objectif donc de cette
rentrée et une massification quelque
part de cette information sur les
métiers que nous souhaitons absolument
développer
l'autre sujet que vous évoquez sur
l'offre de formation je vous rejoins
c'est un vrai enjeu majeur que de la
fois travailler sur cette offre de
formation pour qu'elle soit plus en
réponse aux enjeux aussi de demain quel
est des réponses et des réponses plus
agiles pour les métiers en tension qu'on
puisse être sur du court terme qu'elle
est aussi des réponses fortes pour aller
préparer les compétences de demain c'est
donc tout un enjeu de mise à jour des
contenus de création de nouveaux
contenus de nouvelles formations aussi
qui doivent pouvoir se déployer tout en
étant très attentif à l'effet d'aubaine
aussi que peut avoir la loi de 2018 et
que France compétence s'attache à
maîtriser pour s'assurer aussi que le
travail que nous avons fait de
régulation où nous avons je le rappelle
vraiment élaguer un certain nombre de
d'organismes de formation ou de
formation dont les contenus ne
répondaient pas aux enjeux encore une
fois de projets professionnels
ne prennent pas finalement une autre
forme avec d'autres acteurs donc il
s'agit véritablement à la fois de
permettre cette évolution là et donc
essayer d'encouragé par des cohortes que
je mets en place par de l'action
interministérielle mais dans le même
temps il s'agit aussi d'être très
attentif et de ne pas
laisser s'installer dans le paysage des
organismes de formation qui abusent du
système et qui ont une visée j'ai envie
de dire
financière mais mais surtout qui est
derrière ne rende pas la qualité du
service de formation qui qu'ils doivent
aux apprenants donc voilà il s'agit
véritablement d'équilibrer c'est de ces
deux aspects là
merci
la parole à Michel Calvet
merci madame la ministre de cette
présentation et des évolutions qui
interviennent dont on ne peut que se
satisfaire effectivement et il faudra
continuer alors sur la réforme du lycée
professionnel nous sommes très heureux
de des évolutions que vous proposez
c'est vrai que le lycée professionnel
est bien souvent considéré comme étant
la voie de garage en quelque sorte de la
voie de l'échec elle est trop considérée
ainsi et il faut qu'on arrive à redorer
l'image de l'information enfin des
lycées professionnels de manière
générale pour considérer aussi que ce
sont des lycées de l'excellence et que
cela peut permettre de bien s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle donc il y a
constamment sans doute des efforts à
faire à ce sujet et en particulier
peut-être aussi pour
rattraper ce qu'on appelle les nids ceux
qui sont les jeunes qui sont ni en
formation ni en emploi ni en stage
etc comment peut-on faire est-ce qu'il y
a des des idées qui émergent concernant
la possibilité d'approcher ces personnes
et de pouvoir les réinsérer dans les
cycles de formation
d'autre part sur le catalogue des
formations professionnelles dans le
sentiment que bien souvent c'est un peu
le poids de l'histoire qui fait
fonctionner qui fait mettre en oeuvre
des formations c'est à dire qu'on a
toujours fait et puis on voit bien que
les métiers évoluent autour de nous
est-ce que véritablement
la carte des formations dans les lycées
professionnels aujourd'hui peut évoluer
je dirais de façon efficiente vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure les formations
autour de la cybersécurité par exemple
qui évolue pour s'adapter en permanence
est-ce que le saut est assez important à
ce sujet et puis il y a bien sûr la
question du rapprochement avec des
entreprises on était allés par exemple
dans le Jura pour constater que l'école
nationale de formation à l'industrie
laitière
était très peu en contact avec les
entreprises du secteur et pourtant le
meilleur fromager du monde avait peu de
contact avec cette école ce qui
paraissait à quelques qui a implanté à
quelques mètres de l'école
ce qui paraissait totalement étonnant
donc on voit qu'il y a encore beaucoup
de choses à faire pour rapprocher les
lycées professionnels de l'entreprise et
on est heureux que vous puissiez
proposer un bureau relation entreprise
dans chaque
lycée c'est absolument nécessaire tout
comme il faut aussi permettre je crois
au lycée de pouvoir mieux intervenir
auprès de dans les collèges pour
l'orientation pour faire connaître les
les formations qui existent par exemple
je rencontrais le directeur du lycée
maritime du Guilvinec dans le Finistère
qui me disait qu'il avait toujours
beaucoup de difficultés à approcher les
collèges pour présenter les les
formations or il est nécessaire que
dans un même secteur les jeunes puissent
connaître le type de formation qui est
proposé c'est absolument essentiel quand
dites-vous madame la ministre
merci monsieur le rapporteur Michel
Canevet pour pour l'ensemble de ces
questions au fond je partage votre avis
sur le fait que
le lycée professionnel doit pouvoir
avoir une image qui soit redorée il le
mérite parce que encore une fois il est
stratégique pour les compétences de la
nation c'est aujourd'hui trop souvent
une voix d'orientation subie trop
souvent c'est par le constat d'un niveau
scolaire trop fragile que les élèves
sont orientés j'ai envie de dire deux
faits dans la voie professionnelle trop
souvent aussi qu'on entend des jeunes
qui vous disent que ils souhaitaient
aller vers tel ou tel métier de la voie
professionnelle et que du fait de leur
bons résultats on les a dissuadés
d'aller dans la voie professionnelle
cette réalité elle n'est pas acceptable
et à la fois elle doit aussi faire
l'objet de notre part d'un certain
nombre d'actions pour qu'on puisse
transformer ça c'est à dire qu'à la fois
bien sûr que la voix professionnelle est
très honorable et mérite au fond une
reconnaissance de la société comme étant
stratégique mais surtout porteuse de
professionnalisation vers des métiers de
qualité avec des conditions de travail
et de rémunération et des perspectives
de carrière tout à fait attrayantes et
parfois bien plus que dans d'autres
filières même général donc il s'agit à
mon sens de véritablement transformer
cette image et dans le même temps il
s'agit aussi de faire un travail de fond
au lycée professionnel pour que nous
puissions aller positionner lycée
professionnel comme un acteur
stratégique je m'explique très
clairement pour moi si demain le lycée
professionnel est celui qui forme sur
les métiers de la transition énergétique
de l'écologie du numérique qu'il est au
fond sur des filières qui sont des
filières qui sont tout à fait porteuses
et reconnues par la société nous aurons
aussi une transformation de l'image de
plus si nous avons un lycée
professionnel qui permet également
l'insertion professionnelle la réussite
des élèves au fond l'insertion
professionnelle comme la poursuite
d'études réussie on aura aussi un lycée
professionnel qui sera choisi tant que
comme aujourd'hui on a un lycéen diplômé
sur deux qui n'arrive pas à s'insérer
dans l'emploi et que un élève sur deux
qui poursuit effectivement des études
qui réussit à poursuivre ses réussit à
obtenir le diplôme de cette poursuite
d'études ce sera toujours un
questionnement pour les familles et les
élèves de se dire est-ce que je m'engage
en cette voie donc il s'agit vraiment
d'aller travailler j'ai envie de dire et
sur l'image et sur le fond pour aller
travailler sur toutes les fragilités
circulaires qui existent dans le lycée
professionnel mais qui ne sont pas
inéluctables c'est pourquoi
il y a un certain nombre d'autres
actions qui sont engagées par ailleurs
je le dis pas souvent ce que souvent je
n'ai pas le temps de répondre dans son
entièreté mais encore une fois une
action sur la scolarisation des trois
ans c'est aussi cet objectif-là de
lisser des inégalités de départ on sait
que certains enfants entrent en
maternelle avec 300 mots à leur actif
quand d'autres au même âge avec 2500
mots donc les inégalités elles sont dès
le plus jeune âge donc il faut
travailler des plus jeune âge à lycée
ces inégalités notamment dans le milieu
scolaire et par la scolarisation et puis
évidemment cette se dédoublement des
grandes sections ces PCE vont prendre
leurs effets plus tard mais
véritablement c'est un enjeu pour nous
très fort de renforcer l'accès au savoir
fondamentaux dès le plus jeune âge avec
cette étape également sur laquelle
travaille pas peine sur l'étape CM2 6e
et cette marche qui est parfois vers le
collège est difficile pour les élèves et
donc là aussi on a des situations de
décrochage et de désengagement scolaires
au collège parce que les jeunes
n'arrivent pas à prendre cette marche là
et donc il s'agit comme ça de tout au
long du parcours d'essai de lisser c'est
fragilités scolaires qui donc viendront
prendre leurs effets au lycée
professionnel dans quelques années mais
pour autant dès lors qu'on constate ces
fragilités scolaires qui existent
objectivement on a 7 sur 20 de moyenne
au brevet pour les lycéens en voie
professionnel quand on en a quand on a
une moyenne de 11,7 sur 20 pour ceux qui
sont orientés vers l'enseignement
général et technologique donc on voit
qu'il est fragilités scolaires sont
réelles donc il faut les accompagner il
faut aussi lutter contre le décrochages
et j'ai envie de dire à tout niveau et
c'est pourquoi on va lutter contre le
décrochage et dans le cursus dès leur
qu'on commence à voir d'absentéisme des
premiers signaux de décrochage on va
mettre en place tous les partenaires
arrimés les écoles de la deuxième chance
les épis de l'émission locale tous ces
acteurs qui savent faire avec des jeunes
qui sont en décrochage pour aller
retravailler le projet et du coup
construire avec le sens qu'ils ont envie
de donner à leur parcours mais on va
aussi le faire post diplôme
puisqu'encore une fois un élève sur deux
sorts sans emploi après l'obtention de
son diplôme donc il s'agit de ne pas les
laisser en septembre sans solution et
donc ils seront toujours sous statut
scolaire jusqu'à la fin de l'année qui
suit l'obtention de leur bac pro avec un
engagement d'établissement et des
partenaires pour aller l'aider à faire
une mention complémentaire
rechercher un emploi faire un stage
enfin bref ne pas rester sans solution
et être dans une dynamique active
d'insertion professionnelle et puis le
troisième point c'est qu'on a beaucoup
de décrochés aussi quand il poursuivent
des études et qui se rendent compte
qu'il n'arrive pas à tenir le niveau
finalement de la poursuite d'études et
donc ils seront rattrapés par un
dispositif qui permettra de les
accompagner de leur permettre soit de
continuer du coup sur l'année et de
passer en secondaire soit de faire leur
BTS en trois ans pour éviter le
décrochage en question vraiment un gros
travail sur la découverte des métiers un
dispositif que je n'ai pas évoqué ce
matin mais qui s'appelle diagorient donc
je cherche à faire connaître parce que
c'est un test font des questions qui
sont posées aux jeunes c'est un outil
pour les jeunes et qui les aide à
dégrossir quelque part le projet
d'orientation qui pourrait être le leur
diag oriente c'est une plateforme d'État
qui a développé cet outil
qui vraiment est assez extraordinaire
permet vraiment d'aider le jeûne et son
environnement à dessiner quel pourrait
être les perspectives et du coup aller
ici faire un stage là visiter une
entreprise ailleurs organisé un échange
et puis je voudrais mettre le focus sur
deux points sur le mentorat et les voir
skills je finance les voir ce qu'ils
donc c'est Olympiades des métiers et
notamment la compétition internationale
à hauteur de 25 millions pour la
compétition internationale mais
véritablement c'est un formidable
instrument qui est sur tous les
territoires avec une compétition
régionale d'abord puis nationale puis
international il faut que les acteurs
des territoires et notamment les
collèges et les lycées s'emparent de cet
outil aussi pour faire voir les métiers
mais aussi pas faire partager entre
jeunes parce que c'est souvent comme ça
que ça ça passe bien c'est des jeunes
qui parlent à des jeunes et des jeunes
passionnés qui parlent à d'autres jeunes
de leur voix et c'est véritablement à
mon sens un moment incroyable et une
vitrine incroyable sur les métiers et
puis le mentorat que je souhaite passer
à l'échelle d'ici à 2026 pour que chaque
lycéen professionnel puisse avoir un
mentor s'il le souhaite parce que c'est
souvent des jeunes qui encore une fois
manquent de voilà de soutien aussi
social et familial et qui ont besoin
aussi d'avoir quelqu'un un adulte qui
puisse aussi les aider alors au fond
est-ce que tout ça est suffisant bah
écoutez on va chercher à le faire on va
travailler sur les contenus de formation
on va créer une nouvelle formation on va
assumer de fermer des formations qui
n'en sert pas et qui ne permettent pas
des poursuites d'études réussie il faut
arrêter aussi de d'envoyer des jeunes
dont on s'est pertinemment que les taux
d'insertion sont à 10% et les taux de
poursuite d'études réussit à 10% dès
lors que on sait cette réalité il faut
se dire que on est là pour servir le
jeûne et le permet lui permettre de
réussir et donc c'est à nous en
responsabilité d'accepter de se dire que
la formation ne correspond plus ni la
réalité économique du pays ni finalement
à la réussite de ces jeunes et donc de
d'assumer de fermer des formations de
travailler sur des mentions
complémentaires qui je le rappelle donne
20 points d'employabilité de travailler
sur ces bureaux et que l'entreprise
parce que là encore dans chaque
établissement il s'agit vraiment de
travailler sur les partenariats locaux
d'être au fond le réseau de ceux qui
n'en ont pas et de travailler sur cette
qualité des stages pour que aucun jeûne
et une étude
quelques années montrer que
72% des jeunes trouvent leur stage par
eux-mêmes vous savez quand vous avez 16
ou 17 ans
c'est pas évident et et nos enfants ont
les aide bien souvent à trouver leur
premier stage donc il s'agit aussi de se
dire que ce sont des jeunes qui ont
besoin qu'on les aide à mettre le pied à
l'étrier et ce bureau des stages là il
aura cette bureau des entreprises là
aura cette mission là et puis c'est
toujours les campus des métiers des
qualifications pour travailler en
filière donner de la perspective
partir du moins trois plus cinq elle est
vraiment sur cette capacité aussi pour
les jeunes de savoir qu'ils sont
embarqués dans une filière et un
parcours et puis c'est aussi des
indicateurs je me permets de le dire et
d'une transparence sur ces indicateurs
de réussite qui nous permettent
d'évaluer les actions savoir si au fond
le diplôme est aujourd'hui à 20% taux
d'insertion mais qu'il évolue par le
biais des différentes actions à 60% ou
alors est-ce que effectivement malgré
les différentes actions qui sont mises
en oeuvre on ne parvient pas à faire
évoluer cette photo de réussite et dans
ce cas là il faudra prendre la
responsabilité de fermer la filière et
puis enfin c'est encore une fois la
découverte des métiers et au travers de
la découverte des métiers la question de
l'orientation choisie qui est à mon avis
essentielle
merci Madame la Ministre alors on va
poursuivre peut-être en se tournant vers
l'expresso avant tout j'aurais une
question
on a reçu hier le nouveau président de
principal syndicat agricole nous a
indiqué les perspectives d'emploi dans
le domaine agricole alors évidemment la
formation professionnelle agricole c'est
pas de votre ressort on est dans un
autre silo si on peut employer le terme
cette fois c'est le ministère de
l'Agriculture laissons donc ça de côté
on va pas réformer ça par contre
l'orientation vous en avez largement
parlé est-ce qu'elle intègre la
présentation des métiers de
l'agriculture
parce qu'il y a 90 000 emplois dans les
prochaines années donc c'est maintenant
qu'il faut intéresser les jeunes et une
variété de métier c'est ça ma question
merci monsieur le Président Babari
effectivement la question des lycée
agricoles a été pleinement associée dans
les dans les réflexions la préparation
de la réforme ainsi que
le ministère de de la mer parce que les
lycées de la mer comme les lycées
agricoles bien que j'ai envie de dire
indépendant dans leur dans leur
organisation bénéficie d'un certain
nombre de dispositions et notamment de
la gratification des stages des sacs
rentrés prochaine il s'agit pour toutes
ces spécialités là de les faire
connaître dans la découverte des métiers
c'est essentiel parce que ce sont aussi
des acteurs essentiels aux grandes
transition que nous avons est déjà
évoquées
ils ont un modèle qui aussi nous a
inspiré notamment avec un modèle auto
par exemple des maisons familiales et
rurales avec cette question de
l'accompagnement renforcée avec beaucoup
de dispositifs type internat aujourd'hui
56% des lycées professionnels ont un
internat et moi je suis absolument
convaincu que on a une des réponses
aussi à l'accès à des formations
attractives et un choix d'orientation
qui parfois n'est pas de proximité
géographique pour les jeunes mais qui
peut du coup être accompagnés s'il y a
un internat il y a encore une fois dans
le lycée dans lequel j'étais 100% des
jeunes qui sont en internat réussissent
à obtenir leur diplôme 100%. donc on
voit aussi à quel point c'est aussi un
facteur c'est un internat d'excellence
qui est effectivement mais en place des
dispositifs d'accompagnement mais pour
autant on voit que le taux de réussite
de ces jeunes et d'ailleurs ils le
disent même avec
c'est sympathique parce qu'ils le disent
avec voilà humour en disant bah moi ça
manquait qui toujours d'aller à l'étude
le soir mais pour autant je sais que je
réussis mieux aussi mes études parce que
j'ai cette encadrement là et que je suis
contraint de toute façon aller chaque
soir faire mon travail et être
accompagné pour cela donc c'est on voit
à quel point il y a aussi un modèle qui
peut être inspirant et véritablement moi
je souhaite pouvoir
de jeunes qui sont
originaires du milieu agricole
traditionnel donc les trois quarts ce
sont des gens qui viennent de
l'extérieur et donc en particulier des
zones urbaines très urbaines et donc il
faut les approcher pour leur parler de
des métiers de la culture merci
Chauvin
oui merci président merci madame la
ministre pour les nombreuses
explications et indications que vous
nous avez déjà donné merci à mon
collègue d'avoir cité un problème qui a
été
détecté dans le Jura mais
malheureusement il n'est pas que
jurassien voilà moi j'aurais deux
questions de remarques
tant de je parlerai des jeunes qui
arrivent à la fin de leur cursus donc où
ils ont leur bac pro où ils ont leur BTS
et ils n'exerce pas le métier qu'ils ont
appris et pour lequel ils ont obtenu un
diplôme alors
la raison la raison est ce que vous
arrivez à la détecter ils sont quand
même très très nombreux quoi je pense
par exemple on a également un lycée
hôtelier donc des formations BTS et il y
a un tout petit pourcentage qui part
dans l'hôtellerie mais il y a pas que
l'hôtellerie qui est concerné donc
est-ce que la formation entre guillemets
et un petit peu à dépoussiérer pour que
ce soit plus en adéquation avec vraiment
le concret des métiers
est-ce qu'on est-ce qu'on n'arrive pas
dans le cadre de la formation alors
donner envie d'exercer ce métier voilà
c'est c'est des questions qui
m'interpellent et puis deuxième point
donc vous avez beaucoup insisté sur le
fait que la formation professionnelle
c'est bien sûr l'affaire de l'État mais
c'est également beaucoup l'affaire des
entreprises donc pourquoi pourquoi ne
pas arriver à mettre mieux en adéquation
l'enseignement et l'entreprise puisque
parallèlement nous voyons de nombreuses
entreprises qui se trouvent en
obligation de créer leur propre école de
formation parce que elles n'ont elles
n'ont pas localement
localement elle n'arrive pas à attirer
la main d'oeuvre qualifiée qui leur est
nécessaire donc je pense qu'il y a un
malaise entre les écoles les lycées de
formation et puis ce milieu de
l'entreprise pourquoi eux-mêmes sont
obligés de créer leur école voilà le les
deux points que je souhaitais évoqué
avec vous merci madame la ministre va y
ajouter des questions peut-être de notre
collègue Daniel salmon
proposerait de répondre à ces deux-là
trois avec mon délit qui prendra la
parole juste derrière et puis ensuite on
fera conclure par leurs questions trois
rapporteurs et je regarde
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre pour votre présentation fort
intéressante
vous avez pointé le fait que
un certain nombre
d'apprentis avaient enfin de candidats
avait du mal à trouver
un lieu d'apprentissage comment
expliquer vous que les entreprises qui
sont sous tension ne s'inscrivent pas
dans ces démarches là parce que ça
semble le bon sens de prendre des
apprentis pour pouvoir les former et
après éventuellement les garder donc
quels sont les freins que vous voyez à
cette à cette
recherche par les entreprises des
apprentis sinon un propos plus en lien
avec mon département puisque je suis
sénateur Ille-et-Vilaine vous parliez du
sens dans le travail et puis les métiers
en lien avec la transition écologique on
sait qu'on va rechercher beaucoup de de
personnes dans le bâtiment et en
particulier sur
de matériaux biosourcés je connais un
organisme qui s'appelle ecobatis à main
rock et qui
vraiment travaille en ce sens mais qui
peine à trouver les financements il y a
eu des aides au démarrage de la région
de la Communauté de Communes également
de l'État viademe mais derrière les
financements ne suivent plus et on est
pas loin du décrochage donc voilà quel
suivi est fait sur ces sur ces
organismes qui s'engagent vraiment dans
un projet qui a du sens dans le cadre de
la transition énergétique
je j'interroge aussi Didier Mandelli
oui
dans l'investissement les choses ont été
faites et après c'est dans la
avec les organismes de formation que
derrière il y a des difficultés à avoir
vous savez bien déjà désagrément mais
également des financements
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre nous ne pouvons que nous
réjouir à de l'évolution très positive
de de ce type de formation et de
l'apprentissage le chemin était long et
tortueux mais nous arrivons enfin
nous avons eu la chance à mes collègues
de faire un déplacement en Vendée dans
un magnifique département où il y a un
tissu de TPE et de PME très dense avec
des entreprises capitaux familiaux pour
l'essentiel des grandes entreprises et
nous avons visité également des centres
un centre de formation à campus sur
qui accueille 33000 jeunes et je rejoins
la question de mon collègue Michel
sur
les visites ou les découvertes collège
vous avez indiqué que ce serait
désormais dans le dans le cursus alors
est-ce que ce sera obligatoire
je voudrais avoir cette confirmation
dans le cursus parce que aujourd'hui
enfin ce qui nous a été donné d'ailleurs
en Vendée comme ailleurs 50% en gros des
principaux de collège refuse toute
visite extérieure ou intervention dans
le collège de ce type d'établissement
qui préconise enfin qui propose un
certain nombre de formations et puis je
voudrais aussi vous dire que c'est vrai
que les clichés ont la vie dure sur sur
formation l'apprentissage sur les
métiers que nous connaissons et qui sont
des vraies voies de de d'épanouissement
professionnel et
moi je voudrais vous alerter parce que
le ministre de l'éducation nationale il
y a quelques semaines dans l'hémicycle
dans le cadre des questions d'actu au
gouvernement j'ai été choqué je suis pas
sûr que tout le monde est bien perçu
mais le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a encore évoqué des
voix pour des jeunes qui n'avaient pas
d'autres possibilités ou qui étaient en
échec parlant de l'apprentissage de
cette formation le ministre de
l'éducation nationale et donc je me dis
que
il y a sans doute à ce niveau là aussi
du travail à faire parce que je pense
que les ministres doivent être
exemplaires et indiqués aux jeunes les
voix les voix qui leur conviennent
absolument madame la sénatrice Chauvin
au fond je crois que vous avez raison un
certain nombre de jeunes n'exercent pas
le métier
pour lequel il a été formé c'est ça
tient au fond de à mon sens plusieurs
motivations déjà cette question de
l'orientation subie que j'évoquais tout
à l'heure des jeunes qui à l'issue de la
troisième sont orientés je me permets de
le dire de manière comme ça enfin sont
orientés vers la voie professionnelle du
fait des résultats scolaires et quand on
leur demande qu'est-ce que tu veux faire
bah là comme ça je ne sais pas et donc
souvent souvent ils sont orientés vers
des filières qui ne correspondent pas à
une envie particulière mais souvent par
méconnaissance tout simplement de quels
sont les métiers qui peuvent exister
d'où l'enjeu véritablement travailler
sur sa découverte des métiers qui ne
permet non pas d'orienter bien sûr de la
cinquième mais qui permet au moment où
on doit se poser la question de
l'orientation une meilleure visibilité
de ce que sont les métiers et donc de
pouvoir faire un choix plus éclairé et
bien sûr ce avec l'entourage et ce aussi
accompagner de la transparence sur les
taux d'insertion et taux de poursuite
d'études on a un gros paradoxe entre les
filières qui sont attractives et les
filières qui sont insertes donc on a
aussi besoin de travailler sur certaines
représentations qu'on peut avoir en se
disant que telle formation ressemble le
plus à la voie générale ou technologique
et donc pourraient être effectivement
meilleur qu'une autre et il s'agit aussi
de travailler sur sa transparence sur
les taux d'insertion et de poteau de
poursuite d'études la deuxième chose que
je voulais valoriser c'est la qualité
des stages certains élèves ne font pas
de stage ou les fonds au sein même de
l'établissement ou
les fonds dans des sur des missions qui
ne ressemblent pas véritablement à la
formation sur lesquels ils sont formés
et ou encore
sont effectivement sur des missions qui
ne sont pas valorisées
valorisante et valorisée du coup par par
l'élève donc il s'agit vraiment de
travailler sur la qualité de ces
périodes de stage pour des jeunes et je
me permets de le rappeler des jeunes qui
sont souvent plus jeunes qu'il y a
quelques années puisqu'on ne redouble
plus donc des jeunes qui ont souvent
entre 15 et 18 ans et qui donc en
seconde ou en première année de CAP sont
tout jeunes et donc qui ont besoin en ce
moment-là certes
sont plus dans un stage de découverte
long mais ont besoin d'engagement de
l'entreprise pour faire bien le stage
pour aussi donner de l'attractivité au
métier à la filière donc c'est
véritablement important de travailler
sur cette question de la qualité des
stages et d'avoir un engagement des
entreprises qui soient forts pour faire
le travail aussi de de d'être attractif
pour ces jeunes et pour donner
finalement l'envie aussi de rejoindre
ces métiers c'est aussi une évolution
des contenus de formation vous l'avez
souligné il s'agit véritablement aussi
d'avoir un contenu de formation qui soit
plus adapté au métier d'aujourd'hui les
métiers évoluent donc nos contenus de
formation ils doivent évoluer aussi et
c'est important qu'il soit et ça donne
aussi j'ai envie de dire pour le jeune
du sens que d'avoir une cohérence entre
l'évolution du métier qu'il constate en
stage et les enseignements qui l'a
évidemment lorsqu'il est au lycée
beaucoup évidemment nos enseignants font
évoluer ces contenus de stage mais c'est
important qu'il le soit de manière
beaucoup plus dynamique puis c'est aussi
plus globalement l'attractivité des
filières qui est en question du travail
que font les branches de travail que
font les acteurs eux-mêmes pour être
attractif
organiser cette conciliation entre vie
personnelle et professionnelle organiser
de meilleures conditions de travail un
accompagnement de qualité par un tuteur
par quelqu'un qui dans l'entreprise
partage j'ai envie de dire donne de soi
aussi pour pouvoir accompagner ce jeune
et puis donner du sens voilà on est dans
un métier qui
forcément du sens dans la société et
c'est important aussi pour ces jeunes ça
peut nous paraître à nous évident mais
en fait pour ces jeunes c'est important
aussi qu'on leur redonne du sens et de
l'engagement aussi de l'entreprise dans
ce sens-là il s'agit clairement pas d'un
adéquationnisme entre les diplômes de
l'éducation nationale et les métiers
un la diversité des métiers ne
permettrait pas de développer une offre
de formation adéquationniste de la
temporalité de l'évolution des métiers
et la temporalité de l'évolution des
diplômes et du jeûne qui parcourent ce
diplôme ne permet pas ça non plus et
d'ailleurs n'est pas souhaitable
pourquoi est-ce que ce n'est pas
souhaitable parce qu'au fond ce qui est
important aussi c'est de préparer le
jeûne à être prêt à s'adapter tout au
long de son parcours sur des événements
professionnels et des parcours de vie et
de et professionnels qui l'amèneront de
toute façon à s'ajuster donc il s'agit
vraiment pour nous de lui donner cette
capacité à
à s'adapter finalement aux évolutions du
monde professionnel et donc c'est et
puis c'est un enjeu aussi lisibilité si
on avait autant de formations que le
métier déjà qu'aujourd'hui sincèrement
c'est pas simple de s'y retrouver et
trouver une orientation professionnelle
et les intitulés de diplômes ça fait
partie aussi des chantiers sont
tellement illisibles que c'est pas
simple déjà de s'y retrouver mais là
sûrement plus sur les démultiplierait ça
crée encore plus de complexité il s'agit
très clairement
aussi de donner
de par la mention complémentaire la
spécialisation post-bac de donner cette
spécialisation par le biais d'alternance
par le biais de l'expérience que ces
jeunes acquièrent et par cette relation
qui se crée entre l'entreprise et le
jeûne aussi de l'employabilité de la
cohérence mais c'est tout ça au fond qui
va permettre aussi de concourir à une
meilleure adéquation entre le jeûne son
projet et sa formation et donc son
insertion professionnelle monsieur
salmon les difficultés à trouver des
stages ils sont ils sont réels encore
une fois 72% des jeunes de lycées
professionnels trouvent leur stage par
eux-mêmes et quand on sait le fait
qu'ils sont dans un indice de position
sociale beaucoup plus fragile et qu'ils
ont souvent bien moins de réseau que
d'autres élèves ou les parents d'élèves
on sait à quel point c'est important que
de pouvoir les accompagner sur cette
recherche de stage d'où cet acteur qui
sera essentiel demain et complètement
dédié à la relation aux entreprises et à
l'accompagnement des jeunes et dans leur
réussite c'est véritablement un enjeu
majeur moi je parlais tout à l'heure
plus du lycée professionnel quand je
disais ça aujourd'hui le les CFA les
centres de formation par apprentissage
ont quelqu'un qui est dédié à cette
relation avec les entreprises et à cette
aide aux jeunes pour trouver un
apprentissage et de toute façon le jeune
s'il n'a pas d'entreprise il ne peut pas
faire d'apprentissage donc en fait dans
les CFA cet accompagnement il est
réalisé je souhaite que dans le lycée
professionnel cet accompagnement là
aussi puisse être réalisé parce que sont
souvent des jeunes qui n'ont pas de
réseau et on a très peu de réseaux
d'anciens étudiants on a aussi une
moindre visibilité pour les entreprises
du fait qu'on a besoin sur tel et telle
période d'avoir des entreprises qui
s'engagent pour prendre ces jeunes donc
je mobise beaucoup les entreprises les
réseaux les différents réseaux
d'entreprises mais également toutes ces
entreprises qui déjà sont engagées
vis-à-vis d'engagement sociétaux pour
que on puisse faire changer la donne et
qu'on puisse accueillir mieux ces jeunes
en stage c'est essentiel et c'est
véritablement un des objectifs
poursuivis par la réforme sur la
transition écologique très clairement on
accompagne de nombreuses formations sur
la transition écologique c'était
stratégique donc on a véritablement
besoin de développer les compétences en
la matière dans les lycées
professionnels comme dans les centres de
formation par apprentissage comme dans
l'enseignement supérieur on finance
travers des coûts contrats les
organismes de formation pas plus pas
moins quelque part mais les modalités de
financement sont sur la base des
comptabilités analytiques donc de la
réalité des dépenses engagées donc il
n'y a aucune raison que ces organismes
de formation s'ils sont construits de
manière qualitative et offre j'ai envie
de dire toute la réponse à l'exigence de
certification et qui ne soit pas
accompagné ils le sont au travers des
coûts contrats versés sur sur la base de
chaque apprenti qui dans l'établissement
est formé
il s'agit véritablement pour nous encore
une fois de renforcer cette cet axe là
et encore hier je recevais des acteurs
pour aller renforcer et dans les lycées
professionnels et dans les centres de
formation par apprentissage les
formations à la transition écologique
soit pour donner une teinte soit pour
créer la véritablement des diplômes
dédiés les deux sont absolument
nécessaires
monsieur les députés mandelies
on est sur une découverte des métiers
qui cette année je le disais depuis la
rentrée 2022 et sous forme
d'expérimentation donc effectivement
sont les collèges volontaires qui ont
déployé cette découverte des métiers
rentrée 2022 c'est donc 10 % des
collèges rentrée 2023 c'est tous les
collèges de France qui rentrent dans
cette démarche là c'est ça fera partie
des standards et des choses qui seront
déployées pour tous les collèges de
France et donc tous les collégiens de
France c'est là aussi où l'école sait
faire quelque part elle sait aller
accompagner chacun sur tous les
territoires et au-delà des convictions
quelque part de tel ou tel professeur ou
de l'éloignement géographique de tel ou
tel collège c'est oui bien sûr je suis
d'accord avec vous les clichésions la
vie dure mais en même temps l'image de
l'apprentissage à la largement été
bouleversée je pense que chacun d'entre
nous s'accorde aussi aujourd'hui à dire
que l'apprentissage est une belle
modalité
que nous la souhaiterions pour nos
enfants que parce que aussi nous la
retrouvons à tous les niveaux de
diplômes et parce qu'elle permet une
vraie réussite de ces jeunes parce
qu'aussi on retrouve l'apprentissage
dans tous les secteurs d'activité et
c'est donc au fond ce changement d'image
que je souhaite pour le Lycée
professionnel qui
par le fait que ces jeunes ne
décrocheraient plus par le fait que ces
jeunes trouveront une insertion
professionnelle et réussiront à
poursuivre des études nous pourrons
effectivement ainsi changer l'image du
lycée professionnel comme étant une voix
choisie et une voix qui soit reconnue
par la société c'est la véritablement
mon objectif
et par nous tous
nous reste 3 minutes
non simplement donc pour terminer les
questionnements chacun des rapporteurs à
une ultime question donc on va commencer
on prend les trois et puis on va
commencer
et puis très bien
merci oui alors nous avons beaucoup
parlé du lien
enseignement monde de l'entreprise moi
j'aimerais vous parler du lien à présent
entreprises Pôle emploi alors qui s'est
beaucoup amélioré les entreprises quand
je dis entre je parle surtout là des TPE
PME
donc effectivement les entreprises
reconnaissent que le lien c'est beaucoup
amélioré moi je le constate sur dans mon
département bien sûr qu'un gros travail
a été fait dans le cadre de la création
de France travail comment est-ce que
l'accompagnement des entreprises qui
recrutent dans le recrutement sur la
partie RH sur la partie valorisation de
ce qu'elles font comment est-ce que ces
entreprises seront accompagnées est-il
prévu un renforcement de cet
accompagnement
merci une question très pratique au
pratique le bureau des entreprises
est-ce que c'est le chef des travaux ou
des dfpt qui l'assurera est-ce que c'est
davantage de moyens
deuxième question vous n'avez pas du
tout parlé des lycées des métiers est-ce
que c'est ça reste toujours une
orientation de développer les lycées des
métiers et enfin une dernière remarque
vous avez souligné que les élèves qui
vont au lycée pro sont souvent les
élèves les plus fragiles on va pas faire
un débat sur le lycée pro maintenant
mais est-ce qu'il ne serait pas
intéressante faire un point d'étape 5
ans après leur insertion professionnelle
voir comment on peut les accompagner
vers une évolution
merci président deux observations et une
question première observation sur
l'apprentissage qui est ouvert aux
jeunes de moins de plus de 16 ans pardon
et de 15 ans et un jour pour certains
mais on s'aperçoit que comme il n'y a
plus de redoublement aujourd'hui dans
les classes antérieures bien beaucoup de
jeunes arrivent dans la 15e année par
exemple n'ont pas 15 ans et un jour au
moment de la rentrée mais voudrait
rentrer aussi en apprentissage ce qui a
pas un peu de souplesse à apporter au
sujet deuxième
remarque c'est sur la question des
investissements dans les établissements
notamment pour les questions de logement
des régions s'occupent des lycées mais
pour ce qui concerne les établissements
d'apprentissage des financements sont
plus difficiles et en particulier aussi
pour l'AFPA qui est dans une démarche de
développement de la formation continue
tout au long de la vie qui est un sujet
extrêmement important il faut aussi sans
doute que les des centres de l'AFPA qui
participent à la formation des adultes
puissent être doté de moyens
d'investissement permettant de conduire
leur transformation qui est absolument
nécessaire que ce soit pour l'évolution
des métiers mais aussi pour l'accueil
des stagiaires et cette question du
logement est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important et puis ma question portait
sur le pic qui s'est achevé qui a
mobilisé d'énormes moyens sur l'autorité
de d'une haute commissaire aux
compétences postes qui a été supprimé
les besoins sont évidents en termes d'un
nouveau pic est-ce que il faudrait pas
restaurer le commissaire aux compétences
dont l'action nous a paru assez
pertinente finalement dans son activité
et dans les contacts qu'on a pu avoir
avec
[Musique]
oui cette relation entreprise Pôle
Emploi elle a pour vocation d'être
renforcé aussi par la simplification et
la meilleure coordination entre les
acteurs je le rappelle l'action qui est
menée en matière de compétences auprès
des TPE PME elle est elle est forte
c'est 8 apprentie sur 10 qui sont dans
des TPEPME donc en fait on le sait peu
mais la réalité de l'apprentissage elle
est principalement dans les TPE PME pour
autant au-delà de cela il s'agit
véritablement bien sûr d'aller
accompagner les demandeurs d'emploi sur
cette réalité territoriale cet objectif
de 5% ça sera celle qui sera poursuivie
par France travail vous le savez un
rapport a été remis le 17 avril dernier
avec
différentes
orientations mais au fond l'enjeu il est
surtout d'aller travailler sur une
simplification et
un une meilleure coordination entre les
entre les acteurs avec
l'idée de de bâtir sous une même
bannière cette coordination et ce
pilotage il faut se bien se rendre
compte qu'aujourd'hui 40 % des
bénéficiaires du RSA seulement sont
inscrits à Pôle emploi et donc ça tient
à plusieurs choses mais notamment un
déficit d'orientation et en moyenne seul
17% des allocataires du RSA
sont
ne sont ainsi pas affectés vers un
organisme d'accompagnement donc on voit
qu'il s'agit véritablement d'organiser
des accompagnements plus personnalisés
plus intensifs et d'aller sur des
solutions qui soient aussi plus
systémique si je puis dire d'aller aussi
travailler sur la question des modes de
garde sur le mode de transport sur voilà
cette question aussi des freins qui
peuvent se poser c'est là tout l'enjeu
aussi de France travail d'organiser du
coup l'approche déjà du meilleur suivi
des systématisation du suivi mais
également l'approche assistée systémique
au frein à l'emploi qui peuvent se poser
deuxième sujet lié plus au bureau des
entreprises oui c'est davantage de
moyens puisque ce sera un bureau
relation et que l'entreprise en plus des
acteurs déjà en place pour aller
travailler sur ce développement des
partenariats pour aller travailler sur
cette qualité encore une fois des stages
et cet accompagnement du jeûne dans les
stages en complémentarité de ce que fait
déjà l'enseignant sur son suivi du jeune
pendant qu'il est en stage d'aller
travailler au fond sur l'évolution des
contenus parce que en allant sur une
entreprise ou en échangeant avec une
entreprise
on fait savoir que telle ou tel sujet
n'est plus à l'ordre du jour du métier
et que l'enseignement doit pouvoir aussi
évoluer donc il s'agit véritablement de
travailler en articulation avec les
acteurs des gens en place des dfpt draft
pick qui sont déjà aujourd'hui des
acteurs clés de la professionnalisation
des lycées professionnels il s'agit donc
d'avoir quelqu'un à plein temps et qui
soit donc
identifié par les acteurs entreprises
donc au fond la porte d'entrée de
l'entreprise dans le lycée professionnel
quelqu'un
identifié disponible toute la semaine
pour les entreprises
les lycées des métiers au fond c'est un
label ils existent toujours il existe
toujours un seul label c'est un label
sur la base d'un cahier des charges qui
est donc donné lorsque effectivement
l'établissement répond à un certain
nombre de critères qui sont
issus du cahier des charges qui est
donné donc il existe toujours et il est
complètement complémentaire au lycée
professionnel
c'est ce serait évidemment intéressant
d'avoir un point d'étape 5 ans après
j'ai envie de dire on va le faire nous
même par étape l'idée c'est
véritablement déjà de travailler sur
s'assurer que ces jeunes là trouvent une
insertion professionnelle et une
poursuite de réussir et donc c'est déjà
là mon premier objectif mais oui vous
avez raison de toute façon l'enjeu de
travailler sur le l'emploi et le bon
emploi et la qualité de l'emploi est
essentiel mais ça pour l'ensemble de
notre jeunesse
cette question du logement allait
primordial on a
véritablement encore une fois
aujourd'hui un vrai sujet à pouvoir
développer l'offre d'internat à pouvoir
développer l'offre de logement pour que
ces jeunes qui aussi concilients parfois
un lieu de d'apprentissage et un lieu de
formation
avec toutes les charges que ça engage
puisse effectivement mieux concilier les
choses ça fait partie souvent d'une
offre de formation d'une offre de
logements que propose des centres de
formation
mais
j'ai mais là-dessus c'est aussi au
centre de formation que de pouvoir
proposer des solutions aujourd'hui 56%
des lycées Pro propose de l'internat
77% de taux d'occupation en moyenne donc
on a encore de la place dans les dans
les internats de lycée professionnel et
on sait qu'il participe véritablement à
la réussite des jeunes et sur le plan
d'investissement des compétences
l'expérience montre que enfin
l'expérience du plan d'investissement
sur les compétences du précédent
quinquennat montre plusieurs choses déjà
le fait que la formation a un impact
favorable sur l'accès à l'emploi on voit
qu'un demandeur d'emploi qui se forme à
une probabilité d'accès à l'emploi
renforcée de 9 points par rapport à un
demandeur d'emploi qui ne se forme pas
et cet écart il est encore accru pour
les publics les plus fragiles et les
plus éloignés de l'emploi c'est plus 14
points pour un demandeur d'emploi
inscrit depuis plus d'un an et plus
encore 17 points supplémentaires pour un
demandeur d'emploi de plus de 50 ans
donc on voit à quel point l'enjeu du
ciblage vers les publics les plus
fragiles qui auront du mal à aller vers
l'emploi
est un enjeu très très clairement vers
les publics les plus les plus ou pas
qualifiés les moins ou pas qualifiés
notamment les BRSA les seniors les
demandeurs d'emploi les bénéficiaires de
l'obligation d'emploi on voit aussi
l'importance des savoirs de base et les
compétences socles je me permets
d'attirer votre ascension là-dessus mais
nous avons véritablement un enjeu fort
d'accompagner les les actifs en
situation directrice ou d'électronisme
et également une priorité qui sera
donnée directement sur les besoins des
entreprises pour avoir aussi la une
meilleure contractualisation avec les
régions bien sûr pour aller vers un
niveau d'intervention qui permettent de
l'état global de l'État aux côtés des
régions qui sera vraiment déterminée
dans les prochaines semaines selon deux
dimensions un calendrier qui permettra
d'accompagner les travaux parlementaires
notamment des textes financiers et aussi
un calendrier qui permettra
d'accompagner le dialogue social avec
les partenaires sociaux mais vraiment
aussi à des fins de réponses aux
tensions sur les métiers et au
recrutement pour les entreprises donc il
s'agit aussi de mieux accompagner cette
axe là
merci beaucoup
je vous remercie pour ces échanges très
riches et très détaillé complet et nous
ne manquerons pas de vous transmettre le
rapport quand ça délégation le rat
examiné le 29 juin prochain donc
quelques jours et évidemment pour
compléter nos informations je vous
remercie de pouvoir nous faire passer
les réponses écrites à l'ensemble des
éléments qu'on vous a adressé
chers collègues j'en profite pour vous
rappeler que nous nous retrouvons jeudi
prochain pour l'audition de Livia
Grégoire dans le cadre de la mission
cette fois-ci d'informations sur la
simplification dans l'examen est prévu
le 15 juin prochain notez bien la date
par ailleurs du 21 juin
pour la prochaine édition de la parole
aux entrepreneurs avec Bruno Bouygues
bon vous voyez que notre délégation fait
un travail
considérable merci encore une fois de
vous apprêter au jeu des questions
bonne journée à tous